reaction Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett and former acting attorney
general Matt Whitaker gentlemen both
thanks for being here Greg let me start
with you axio is just reporting a couple
hours ago that Kevin McCarthy says an
impeachment inquiry would require a
house vote now Nancy Pelosi didn't hold
the House vote either time uh in the
first impeachment or the second which
was a snap what do you make of
McCarthy's insistence on a on a vote and
does it change the process
well it does change the process in a
meaningful way I mean McCarthy it seems
is going to be fair you know there'll
either be a house inquiry committee or a
select committee
it'll have both sides on it you'll
recall in the first impeachment of
Donald Trump uh secretive hearings in
the basement of the House Republicans
were allowed to attend but that's about
it they weren't given subpoena power
they couldn't call their own Witnesses
they were limited and restricted in
cross-examination so it was essentially
a sham and then they didn't vote out of
the committee but it simply went to the
floor or Democrats had the vote the
second impeachment was even worse they
didn't even bother to hold in any
hearings it was a snap impeachment here
I think McCarthy is determined to be
fair
Matt you've been at the highest levels
of the justice department the highest
level of the justice department how
common are government officials using
one of them which is a dot gov account a
couple of more Gmail accounts
pseudonym's alternate email addresses to
pass information inside government or to
others like Hunter Biden
yeah well it's good to be with you Pete
and you know regular order is always the
most important thing and I know when I
took over at the Department of Justice
that was you know my main Mantra was
regular order and I'm glad to see
Kevin's doing that in the house unlike
Nancy Pelosi who exercised sheer
Politics as Greg mentioned now the
pseudonym thing is very interesting
because you know typically you're you
know it's it's known that the principal
has one of these accounts so that they
can conduct Business Without You know
all the spam that's going to come in at
the highest level it's the Gmail account
and it's also the multiple accounts
that's very concerning in this case and
obviously we're just scratching the
surface right now Pete on these multiple
thousands of emails that that the vice
president was sending uh to Hunter his
son including information and unknown
and not classified but certainly sense
of information about Ukraine and other
topics that Hunter was certainly very
interested in for business purpose for
sure and Greg this regular order as Matt
points out it gives the power to whether
it's a select committee or an
impeachment inquiry to subpoena these
records are they going to see unredacted
these emails would they see unredacted
bank accounts would they have a chance
to actually get to the bottom of it
hence a war room being assembled in the
White House at this point
yeah I mean look uh yes they would if
they use a select committee uh they
would have absolute authority to obtain
unredacted Alias emails
5400 Joe Biden was using over eight
years as vice president that's more than
two a day and so I think in there you're
going to find some pretty astonishing
information about how Joe Biden uh was
working with his son in these influence
peddling schemes and you know you've
played a clip of it a moment ago he
laughs it off uh well bribery is an
impeachable offense in the Constitution
and the marisma Scandal alone contains
compelling evidence of influence
peddling which the criminal codes
describes is bribery you know using your
public office to confer a benefit in
exchange for money and merisma in
Ukraine notoriously got to benefit
courtesy of Joan investigation that's
suddenly vanished when he demanded the
Ukrainian prosecutor be fired in the
meantime his son gets millions of
dollars in return that is the definition
of bribery in the criminal codes it's
right there in the codes it's right
there in the Constitution Matt but if
you turn it to other channels right now
it is wall-to-wall 18 mug shots Atlanta
indictments hearings cameras in the
courtroom Donald Trump Donald Trump
Donald Trump as it often is how much
legal Jeopardy though are the bidens
actually in should there be an an
inquiry that connects the dots that so
far cable news and a few house
committees have had to connect I mean to
what to what Greg said I mean this
strikes to the heart of what it means to
be the president what it means to hold
classified information to use your
influence
um how far would this go
well it can go a long way and it's going
to be the deliberate drip drip drip of a
impeachment inquiry that is ultimately
going to do the significant damage to
Joe Biden and his presidency because if
you remember uh the in Watergate it took
a long time for that case to build and a
lot of shoes had to drop and I think in
this case in particular you know as Greg
points out there's a prima facie case
right now for bribery and as they build
this impeachment inquiry Brick by Brick
I think we're gonna the American people
are going to learn a lot more about what
Joe Biden was doing as vice president
and how involved his son Hunter was as
The Bag Man and as the person
negotiating these deals so that the
whole family could be enriched and their
lifestyle could accelerate well beyond
uh you know the 40 Years of public
service that Joe's lifestyle had
provided to that point pay very close
attention to when Rank and filed
Democrats in the house or the Senate
start to pay attention and say this is
something worth looking at because there
there's enough smoke Greg and Matt
thanks for breaking it down hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else